The new Japanese government has set a very ambitious target...
...for a greenhouse gas emissions reduction of 25% by 2020,...
...if compared to the 1990 level.
It has also made it clear that it is prepared to provide more financial and technical assistance...
...to developing countries than in the past,...
...in accordance with the progress of the international negotiations.
This international commitment is premised on the formulation of a fair and effective international framework...
...by all major economies and agreement on their ambitious targets.
Japan announced this ambitious pledge because it wishes to serve as a bridge among countries...
...with varied interests and to preserve the planet for future generations.
I would like to appeal strongly to the distinguished representatives present today.
Let us work together to ensure the success of the upcoming Copenhagen meeting.
The third challenge is that of nuclear disarmament and non-proliferation.
I welcome the progress being made in the negotiations on nuclear weapons reductions...
...between the United States and the Russian Federation.
I also commend the United Kingdom and France for their initiatives.
It is urgent that all nuclear weapon holding states take concrete measures on nuclear disarmament.
There are states currently engaged in efforts to develop nuclear weapons.
Furthermore, there is an increasingly greater risk that nuclear materials and nuclear technologies...
...will be passed on to terrorists or even actually used.